it's impressive uh God of War
um we knew this was gonna sell well we
always knew I I am curious to see how
many of those was that bundled oh no
debunked already by Benji sales bungee
sales already ready for y'all he said
for those trying to say it was the bug
news it is not the case so yeah we we
already had it at
so I'm curious they didn't sell a bundle
of God of War in it no I'll get you I'll
get you the exactly that was in every
picture I seen
literally got in front of that for
people saying that it was just bundles
on that situation no I'm not saying it's
just bundles I'm saying that did
contribute to its numbers I'm gonna get
the tweet I should have had it ready but
you continue keep talking keep talking I
mean here's is the thing okay here we go
legitimately LM laughing at people
saying this is primarily driven by
bundle spoiler alert it's not the
majority of all Ragnarok copies sold
have been Standalone but to